In a previous video, we talked about the idea of Ludonarrative Dissonance:
A situation where the story being told by a game's mechanics disagrees with the story being told by a game's narrative,
and people had a lot of interesting and curious responses.
But one example that people brought up stood out to me because it demonstrated, not a misunderstanding of dissonance,
but perhaps a misunderstanding of how games interact with narrative structure.
So let's talk about the Stanley Parable, Dark Souls, and Intended Play.
*Intro Music*
The Stanley Parable is a 2011 piece of First-person interactive fiction that revolves around a conflict between the player
protagonist, Stanley, and the game's narrator. As the player works Stanley through the game, the narrator
exposits his actions, including immediately upcoming actions that serve as
instructions.
(Narrator): When Stanley came to a set of two of open doors, he entered the door on his left.
The player chooses whether to follow these instructions
or to attempt to subvert them in some way.
(Narrator): This was not the correct way to the meeting room, and Stanley knew it perfectly well.
Dark souls, also published in 2011, is a third-person role-playing game where the player takes on the role of "The Chosen Undead," a
cursed human tasked by a vague
prophecy with rekindling the first flame to preserve the Age of Fire. Now, these two games are all in all very
different from one another but they're illustrative for our point here because they both utilize elements of
intentional disobedience. Games have a dimension of interaction that means there's not merely intended
interpretation but also
intended play. The intended interaction with a movie is pretty straightforward. The movie starts
and you watch it.
There are some subversive or alternative forms of watching, such as riffing a movie or the sing-along or
whatever the hell midnight screenings of The Room count as.
*audience screaming the word spoons*
But generally speaking, it's pretty well bounded. This interaction in games means that games can do something that other media
rarely can outside a very experimental
context: which is to tell the participant to do one thing while expecting them to do another. The Stanley Parable
makes this process overt. The entire interaction paradigm of the game more or less revolves around this single principle,
which is what makes it so illustrative.
But it's not actually a niche type of interaction. Any
open-world game has a moment where the player is told to do one thing and can then choose to
immediately turn around and go the other direction,
opting instead to spend dozens or even hundreds of hours doing
anything else but the thing that they were asked to do.
Some games address this within the fiction, such as the Assassin's Creed games that suggests the player is playing a somewhat
scrambled version of the stories events. That, while Ezio may have jumped across all these roofs,
he didn't necessarily do it for five straight hours one afternoon instead of stabbing minor borges in the neck.
Others, like Final Fantasy 7, opt to ignore the disconnect entirely,
operating on the logic that it's only weird if you call attention to it. Games are
constantly telling us to do one thing and then waiting to see if we
actually do it.
The Stanley Parable uses this to create a conflict between the player and the game, but at the end of the day that's just a
costume put on an otherwise ordinary
interaction. The Narrator is simply a disembodied antagonist, like SHODAN or GLaDOS, and,
much like GLaDOS, The Narrator of the Stanley Parable tells you to do or not do specific things
while the game fully expects you to ignore those requests.
(GLaDOS): Welcome to the final test.
(GLaDOS): When you are done,
(GLaDOS): you will drop the device in the equipment recovery annex.
Now those examples are all cases where a
character within the game issues explicit instructions,
and it's pretty clear that disobeying those instructions is core to the game, and possibly even the plot. Doing
what GLaDOS tells you to do
generally results in death.
(GLaDOS): We are pleased that you made it through the final challenge,
(GLaDOS): where we pretended we were going to murder you.
But these two
operating layers still exist even in less overt
games. Games are constantly telling us through various cues how the game expects us to behave in and
interact with its world. This is encapsulated in tutorials, but also environmental
communication and reinforcing desired play styles. The Assassin's Creed games are positively lousy with icons,
indicators, and things that blink and glow to draw your eye and encourage
interaction. It is a game series that sits on the verge of
screaming at you about the many things it wants you to do. As is the case with Dark Souls, the game may simply use standard
game language to imply that you shouldn't behave in a certain way, that some NPCs
you shouldn't kill because they're your friends, or maybe just your allies, or at the very least just because they're not
your enemies. These characters are friendly or they sell you things so you should leave them alone.
That, the game says, is the correct way to behave.
But that's simply a social contract between you and the game simulacrum of friends, and the game
absolutely intends for you to murder
every last one of them. If you go on a rampage in Dark Souls and kill
every last friendly NPC, you will actually unlock whole new side stories, and dungeons, and bosses.
This is not simply emergent or procedural, this is intended play.
If there is crafted content on the other side of your misbehavior,
then it's not actually misbehavior. Because it turns out that murdering everyone is also the correct way to behave.
What a game intends for you to do includes not only the things the fiction of the game tells you to do
but also the broader things the game permits you to do. If there is something that the game's author simply flat-out,
100% did not want you to experience, did not want you to engage in,
then it wouldn't be there. Even when it comes to potential misbehavior using the rules of the system you're placed within,
externalities that they didn't or couldn't account for, like throwing garbage at NPCs,
the only truly accurate sign that the authors don't want you doing that is
that nothing happens at all. This is because even a negative reaction, even the game pushing back against misbehavior, is
content. This is a big challenge when writing about video games: that the text of a game includes not only the messages
intended and implied by the game's explicit plot and the ideas reinforced by the repetitive, mechanical
behaviors the game utilizes,
but also a variety of potentially dramatically diverging intended
postures of play. A reading of Dark Souls must encompass not just the nominal story
but also a breadth of possibilities and how those possibilities
alter the reading. This added complexity means that games as texts are harder to encompass.
But it also means that games as a medium provide a potentially far denser
package for meaning than other forms.
And I understand why this trips people up, this
idea that doing something the game is telling you not to do is
in fact what the game wants you to do because it's something the games authors have accounted for and have
programmed it to respond to. It's the treachery of images, but the treachery of
content.
So what do you think? What's your favorite moment in a game
where it tells you not to do something that it ultimately intends for you to do, and why is it the "Genocide Route" in Undertale?
Let me know in the comments.
*Outro Music*